au 5e jour de l'invasion russe la
situation est toujours extrêmement
tendue en Ukraine les négociations
entamées aujourd'hui entre les deux
parties non d'ailleurs pas fait cesser
les bombardements à Tours la communauté
ukrainienne se mobilise c'était le cas
ce weekend à la manœuvre bien de
nombreuses ukrainiennes des femmes venu
étudier ou s'installer chez tout il y a
chez nous il y a plusieurs années
inquiétude et colère comme un pull
constater Aurélie Renaud Maria 20 ans
Nina 43 ans Nina également 70 ans il y a
quelques jours ces trois femmes qui
vivent aujourd'hui en France ne se
connaissaient pas le rassemblement
contre la guerre dans leur pays natale
les a réunis Maria est étudiante en
médecine à Tours seul sa maman et deux
de ses sœurs vivent en France les autres
membres de sa famille sont à Odessa je
suis en colère
peur de voir que ma ville natale où j'ai
grandi où j'étais depuis toute mon
enfance toute mon essence j'ai il est en
train de se faire bomber
en ce moment je suis désolé pour
l'instant la seule chose qui peut me
remonter le moral c'est du soutien
émotionnel et j'aimerais bien qu'il y
aura plus du monde au moins venir faire
les manifestations comme nous on est en
train de faire en ce moment
Nina et son mari Jean-François vivent
dans le Sud Touraine depuis 14 ans où
ils tiennent des chambres d'hôtes la
jeune femme a réussi à avoir sa famille
chaque jour au téléphone tout le monde
est dans le sud de l'Ukraine mon frère
avec sa famille les cousins cousine le
petit neveu le petit neveu de de 5 mois
qui est là c'est c'est juste horrible
que voilà qui sont restés tous là-bas
ils ont obligé de vivre dans le sous-sol
j'arrive pas de me déconnecter je suis
toujours sur les infos français
européenne je dors tout pas beaucoup je
sens que on va je vais me faiblir nina
est installé en France depuis 17 ans
elle est aujourd'hui à la retraite sa
fille et ses petits-enfants vivent au
centre de l'Ukraine nina a peur mais
dernièrement c'est la colère qui monte
et il veut deux choses liberté
démocratique c'est tout et c'est pas
possible avec rousse avec Poutine c'est
pas possible là-bas c'est prison Baulac
comme ça et c'est tout
désormais ces trois femmes sont liées
elles se sont fait une promesse elle
reviendront ici devant la mairie de
Tours pour demander le soutien de leur
pays